okay
there's a series of steps which are in
common between all of us no matter what
you measured and then there will be some
things where you go off and you'll do
something separately depending on what
you're looking at okay so here's the
common part
we all took pairs of measurements every
time we took two measurements and they
went together okay the first measurement
was what we used the clinometer for
right which was this angle
okay like so right now let me just um
let's pick one example um peter you
measured the flagpole right what was one
of the angles any any angle that you
measured
52 degrees okay so my diagram's not to
scale that's clearly not 50 degrees but
that's fine
now with that angle
you should also have measured that
distance that length right so how much
time nine point four yeah
okay
right
now it's at 91 i think so it's all right
so here's what we're going to do with
this okay wait are you sure it wasn't
like 94 inches or anything like that
i'm not sure i just said
we'll call it 9.4 meters from now and
we'll check it later okay
now you'll have some different
measurements but here's what we're going
to do right we want to find this
how high is this thing right now i
should actually be careful see um we're
standing on the ground in my diagram
right but remember i told you that we're
actually measuring from your eye point
okay that's where the angle is coming
from okay so later on you're going to
need to work out what your height is
added on to this okay
the part that we're going to get from
trig is just this part from your eye
upwards not including your height okay
so i'm going to call this h for height
okay so we'll call that one h over there
now what do we got here you're an angle
over there in the corner
and just like before i want to work out
now which ratio is going to be useful to
me
okay now you have a look i've got this
side which is
opposite the angle
and i've got this side which is
adjacent to the angle so i should use
ten yeah you can see it's
that one okay so 10
52 in this case right degrees
or equal to opposite on adjacent
h over
9.4
okay so do we
the heights what you're going to find
out through trig right so for example
here's what we're going to get
i can get this 9.4 over the other side i
can multiply so 9.4
52 degrees okay so you get your
calculator there
and you say well what is 9.4 times tan
52 degrees
check it out
and you get well i've got this
i've got
and so on meters now does that sound
like a flagpole to you yes no it's
swelling
yeah reasonably like if you could
picture like 12 meters is kind of like
uh let's see
um divide 12 by like 1.7
maybe so that's like seven people end to
end does that seem about right
yeah it's in the ballpark at least okay
and here's the important thing you will
have multiple measurements for your
angle and for your length right or you
may have measured another object okay so
here's what i want you to do i want you
to come up with as many of these as you
can it's like i've taken my measurements
for the height of the flagpole and i've
got this measurement and another one
another one another one
are they the same are they different how
different are they you might have done a
building
or a tree or whatever okay so i want you
to group up with the people who measure
the same object as you
and work out where these numbers are
okay off you go okay everyone let's uh
let's discuss this now
um i'm going to get some measurements
off you for two things i'm getting these
because specifically i know that we have
several measurements for them that we
can compare sometimes we had no
measurements unfortunately but you can
have a look at doing them maybe later
and trying to compare we already have
one full of flagpole but apparently
we've got a measure of 12 meters what
were the other ones can you help me out
maybe give it to me um one decimal place
would be good so this would be 12.0
what was another one
6.0
and 12.0 was there any other
measurements that you guys got no that
was it okay
but that's yeah did other people do the
flagpole no one knows
didn't you guys do this yeah what did
you get ten meters
ten point ten point seven two five
seven okay and eight point three eight
point three okay are you there for a
second
jacob do you have some measurements for
the building three of them three yeah
what do you what do you got first one
was eight point five one meters
yep
the second one was three point two four
point two yeah
you got 3.2 twice did you all right okay
now let's have a look at this
hmm
um from both of these sets of data you
can see something very interesting for
instance you compare these two right
uh you compare these two
there is a huge margin of error in there
okay now this is actually very very
important
amy chloe do you guys mind waiting
outside for me is that okay why
because you're disturbing the rest of us
oh wait
okay we're comparing these and we said
oh man these are huge differences
clearly something's gone wrong okay now
i think we've thought of some of the
things that could go wrong for instance
we came up with a pretty obvious one
here what was what was the discrepancy
between these yeah good so if i just do
a really rough sketch of like here's the
ground leading towards the serpentine
wall and then there's some steps and
then there's like you know this area
right so if you've got your flagpole
where is the flagpole is it here no
there's another finish there you're
further up i'm just going to draw it
there okay now obviously if you're
measuring from down here
versus measuring from here
okay these people are different heights
they're like different meters apart just
vertically right so that's where
something like this can creep in okay
however then you lead to problems like
this now these were not from clearly
different heights okay uh it was sort of
i mean i don't think it was perfectly
level but it was reasonably level okay
and you had like some building over here
and i think the three measurements were
what five meters away
ten so that's like twice as far and then
27 is like all the way over here
okay now this is a legit question why
would the oh differences be so huge
right now i think we'll get an answer if
we have a think about what the triangles
look like okay so here's here's this one
here which is the closest one okay so
measuring this angle in here i'm going
to have a few so i'm going to give them
different names okay i've got now for
there i've got
beta here and then i've got
i think i call that gamma okay now
just think with me on this one in
particular
think about this angle this one will
give you the most information right now
do you remember
when you were doing this right and
you're holding it and you're trying to
do up and down okay
how how difficult did you find it to get
it like completely still and get an
accurate measurement
it was it was pretty okay yeah
here's the tricky thing right when
you're back over here okay
a tiny fluctuation in your arm makes the
difference of say like maybe two degrees
maybe two degrees which doesn't sound
like a lot does it like for example if i
was over here there's hardly a
difference between 70 degrees and 72.
not a big deal okay
but if you're over here right and
because this angle is very small right
supposedly far away enough that it was
like four degrees maybe or if you're off
by two degrees
four and six are hugely different right
like one's a whole 50 bigger than the
other right which is why some of these
measurements are off by such incredible
margins